you can't spell adidas without a I dad
and if I ever lived in a world with
artificial intelligence dad's hello and
welcome to this video my name is grace
Helbig if you haven't subscribed to this
channel yet you should subscribe to this
channel is that too much up front
because I can't take it back but I can
continue to develop a deep regret for it
my camera stopped recording it's as if
some force outside of myself just wants
me to stop this
ignore it welcome to this favorites
video usually people do favorites videos
at the end of the month but I'm doing
them now and a lot of people right now
are uploading their favorites of 2015
like an all-encompassing one year of
favorites video and that's not what this
is is just my favorites that I've been
using most recently first yeah can you
see yeah you see yeah you see at this is
the thing that all of the ladies and
some men on the internet are losing
their goddamn your wreaths rose over its
the Becca under eye brightening
corrector that's just shmoop this is an
under-eye concealer that was given to me
by Diane who I work with and she told me
that all the beauty gurus on YouTube
we're going so crazy over this that like
all of their eyelash extensions were
falling out and I had no idea but I
tried it and I really liked it I smash
it under my eyes and it makes me look
like I slept which is as foreign to me
as French gin and pitbull stays you come
back I spoke a little bit of French in
this video that deserves a thumbs up am
i right Cricut I'm impressive as sorry
lift you're probably thinking hey grace
great thing you found an under-eye
concealer that you really like cause you
look worn out well I am you wanna know
why I spent four hours today in four
hours yesterday recording my audio book
for grace and style
speaking of audiobooks know where you
guys can find a wide selection of
audiobooks so wide it includes but is
not limited to 150 thousand different
audiobooks it's audible calm her breath
heavily singing
that's how much that thing she loves
audible you can download the audiobook
of my first book Grace's guide you can
download a ton of other youtubers
audiobooks and you can download your
first audio book for free if you go to
audible.com slash Grace you know the
drill and if you don't know the drill
welcome to the drill audible.com slash
grace get to your first audiobook
download for free do you like that deal
good job explaining this me now back to
me next Matt can't see you can't see ya
can you fail this is the Urban Decay
brow box this has been in a favorites
video of mine before I recently rebut it
and I guess what like it again
it's basically an all-encompassing brow
kit it opens in two parts the top part
has your colors here and I'm in the
color honeypot and then it comes with
some wax that you use to set your hairs
in place and then if you open the bottom
part KaBlam me there's a little mirror
here and there's two little tiny angled
brushes for applying and they're so tiny
that I feel like Lenny from of mice and
men I just wanted a pom cute next Matt
can't say TSA I can't see yeah this is a
lip liner this specific lip liner is not
necessarily my favorite that I've been
using but I'm using this to represent
lip liners in general I have more so
been using lip liners as a lip color
than lipsticks and stains because it's
easy and I like it this is the NYX nude
pink which I appreciate because that's
exactly what this color is I have it on
my lips right now I got a bunch of other
lip liners that are like nude and berry
oh these are all from Rimmel London
because when I was in Australia over
Christmas doing some no filter shows I
was shopping and I saw the inner
drugstore they had these nude lipsticks
by Kate Moss this whole line and I was
like oh that's so cool I've been looking
for them since I got back to the States
and I haven't found them anywhere and I
really wanted them so I kind of just
bought these to fill the void next me
can't say I can't say okay these are
Tanya burrs lip glosses one of these or
both of these
I don't even know one or both of these
was given to me as a gift from Ingrid
Nilsen loved it I've been meaning to get
myself some ever since I heard Tania
came out with them and one
the packaging is super cute and makes me
feel like a girl with their [ __ ]
together Thank You Tonya for giving me
false hope and - the colors are really
pretty especially these - this one is
called daydream and this one is called I
found Nemo she whimsical is that and
they're not super sticky so when you
have it on you don't have that weird
fish mouth thing that happens when you
go to open your mouth and the lip gloss
makes your lips stick together and
you're like being your girl socks max
yeah I can't say yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah this is like a sex toy for the face
this is a clear sonic I finally got
myself one this is the Clarisonic Mia
it's like the basic version I haven't
been using it long enough to be honest
with you to see huge major changes but
it does give me the illusion that
because I'm using it my skin is getting
cleaner and thinking that you're cleaner
is half of the battle of Hygiene it's
got the beautiful like phone vibrating
sound which is fun because my body has
like a natural annoyed reaction you go
like this if you didn't know I should
call this my skin care routine because I
just gave you a tutorial next me can't
say can't say these are black ankle
boots that I've been wearing a lot
recently I got them from H&M they're
slightly more aggressive than the other
black boots that I have and because they
have this lining in the top is like this
fake shearling sheepskin lining which
allows this part here to not rub on my
beautiful delicate cankles
yay next me yes they a can you say okay
I'll say it these are new adidas
sneakers that I got or adidas for all
those people that like to make words
more complicated than they actually are
to be fair I have never worn these yet
but I got them and with my eyeballs I
like them a lot they have a little bit
of a wedge inside which is super cute I
like the visions I have
me wearing them who knows if I'll
actually wear them and hate them look
this is love at first sight I don't want
to get in a relationship with you and
then you have like so many issues
because I have so many issues and like
if we both have so many issues that's
gonna be like so many issues you can't
leave me well there you go guys there
are my favorites for the month of
January sure I don't think I forgot
anything but I have been talking so much
that I've worked up a sweat
I better wipe my brow cheese that's
better
I hope you guys enjoyed this video give
a thumbs up if you like videos any
videos at all ever at any point in your
life if you've ever enjoyed a video give
this video a thumbs up for that and
don't forget to subscribe I don't know
next can you see it can you see it you
can't see it it's the Netflix series
making a murderer which Wow I'm sure
you've heard of it a lot of people are
talking about it and I'm not gonna say
anything highly opinionated here because
lord knows that's not what the
Internet's for but I encourage you to
watch it because it's just so
fascinating if you feel like you haven't
been feeling irritated by human beings
enough lately then I highly recommend
making a murderer it is as addictive as
it is frustrating it's a lot like this
YouTube channel